(bells jingling)
- [Woman] Have you ever
wondered if you watched
the snow long enough, what
stories it might tell?
There is someone who has done it.
His name is Billy Barr.
- [Billy] I spell it,
- [Woman] Some people call
him the Snow Guardian.
He lives in a cabin out in the woods.
- Picture this, it's a snowy
day, it's dark and cold,
and you make a fire and
you're sitting by the fire
and you're reading with a cup of tea,
and it goes on for nine months.
- [Woman] Billy lives alone
in his house he helped build.
Here he grows his garden.
Has an impressive hat collection.
Loves cricket,
and dreams of Bollywood.
Every couple of weeks, he skis back
into the nearest town for supplies.
He's been doing this for
more than 40 winters.
But Billy does a little more
than just read and drink tea.
For those 40 winters, Billy
has kept a meticulous record
of snow in his little part of the world.
- Okay, the market's at...
February 26th, 1978: 10.5
inches of snow that day;
January 20th, minus 11.5;
April 28th, 1980, I was
41 during that snow storm.
1997, one-half inch new
snow, a weasel was roaming
around inside the shack.
Damn, the birds were back.
I lived in an 8x10 foot, old
shack that had no electricity,
no water, and I had nothing
and I was just there all day.
The main thing I interacted
with was the weather
and the animals.
So I started recording things
just 'cause it was something to do.
I had nothing to prove,
no goals, no anything.
So, actually a researcher at
a lab wanted to look at it,
and then once he started looking
at it scientifically,
then all of a sudden these
decades worth of data
were being used for more
than my own curiosity.
- [Woman] Billy has done
this everyday, twice a day,
all winter long.
- I'd keep going until the snow was gone.
If it snowed, I'd record
that no matter when.
The trend I see is that we're
getting a permanent snow
pack later and we get
to bare ground sooner.
With how the years were,
there was a lot of snow
on the ground and then we
lost snow sooner than years
that had a lot less snow just
because it's a lot warmer now.
- [Woman] In a normal
winter, you'd expect to have
four to five record high temperatures.
Last year, Billy recorded 36.
- Not only is it a lot
warmer, we're getting
a lot of dust blowing in.
As soon as you get dust on
the snow, it melts like that.
You're talking about the
snow pack, the water supply
for most of the southwest.
I'm not real hopeful just because...
I don't know how you
reverse something like that.
- [Woman] As we leave Colorado behind,
Billy imparts once last bit of advice.
- It's like anything else, I
learned to ski to get around,
I learned how to ski
better so I wouldn't fall
down all the time.
Over a period of time I kinda learned
how to survive in this environment.
Actually, learning to fall is probably
the most important thing.
If you're gonna fall, sit.
A lot easier falling on
your butt than on your face.
(somber music)
(musical chime)